they are like two windows through which
we look at the world the world I'd look
at is the same but what they see is
quite different I'm Francisco ji Allah I
am a professor at the University of
California here in Irvine and my main
field is genetics and evolutionary
biology which is what has become my main
interest in study of human evolution
well control and how do we explain what
we are I won the Templeton Prize because
the euros in their wisdom decided that I
was the person who is thought to have
contribute significantly to the
development of the spiritual values of
humankind I was a student of theology
for five years but already with towards
the end of my third year my fourth year
I have become very interested in
studying human evolution and evolution
in general and genetics well it was an
unusual turn is not very common but it
is not extremely unusual either I
eventually didn't practice as a priest
in the usual way but I remained very
interested in theology and in religion
and religious issues as the years went
by you can say either matured or changed
my mind or whatever I felt that was more
interesting for me to become a scientist
science and religion are not the
contradiction they don't need to be
because they deal with different
subjects they are like two windows which
we look at the world the word they look
at is the same but what they see is
quite different science deals with the
composition of matter the expansion of
the galaxies the functioning of
organisms the origin and diversity of
organisms religion deals with the
meaning and purpose of life with a
relation of people to their creator and
to each other with the moral values that
inspire our lives so they are completely
different subjects contradiction arises
only when people transgress their
boundaries when scientists would argue
that science makes it very likely that
God does not exist which of course is a
nonsense statement how because science
cannot say anything about God or more
often when religious people for reasons
like literal interpretation of the Bible
or otherwise denies the accomplishments
of science
keeping creationism or intelligent
design out of science classes is very
important for two reasons one is because
there's a lot of science to teach we
should not be teaching something else
for another reason that to the extent
that we may imply that these matters are
scientific we do harm to science and we
do harm to religion as well because it's
conflating two areas which should be
kept separate and it's not good for
either one so we don't want to teach
astrology as an alternative to astronomy
or witchcraft as an alternative to
medicine or alchemy as an alternative to
chemistry we don't want to teach
intelligent design of creation is misil
tentative to evolution they don't belong
in there certainly for a scientist and
evolutionists like myself looking at the
world and the beauty and the tremendous
diversity and richness of the living
world
and the Magnificent attributes of human
species and other organisms that can be
a source of religious inspiration and
and of course little motivation it
sometimes sometimes grounds for
scientists to go on with their studies
so I think they can complement each
other science is a very interesting way
of knowing but it is not the only way
and you know science has nothing to do
for example with aesthetic so with
beauty of with morality and for many
people in the world those matters are
more important than scientific knowledge
by the model norms the world principles
the model codes according to which we
decide what is good and what is evil
that does not come from science moral
values come from all the sources like
religion or cultural traditions and the
like of social preferences there are
certain moral values that one can see
has been intimately associated with the
real world to an extent that we can say
they they are moral facts is not
something that comes from religion or
culture for example not to kill they
think even about that cultures many more
in the past but even at present who
believed that you can kill a suit kill
under certain circumstances sometimes
citizens that we will not justify but
even in the knighted States we have the
the death penalty there are many
countries in the world most of Western
Europe who think this a barbarian
groaning in a way which many people
refer to it is the cloning of whole
organisms I think this in principle a
good thing because actually farmers
animal breeders try to do that have been
trying to do that for many ways in an
imperfect way by for example selecting a
ball that produces good progeny and then
having all the cars in the head been
submitted by a single board so they are
genetically similar as possible it's a
kind of approximation to cloning we can
do it now much better with science now
cloning human cells is okay cloning
human beings is not in my view alright
for a number of reasons the first one is
technically you cannot do it and I don't
mean that that technically the
techniques are not sufficiently
developed I think that it is impossible
in principle because the people who
think that you can clone human beings
are people who think that what we are is
determined by our genes but what we are
is not determined by our genes is the
terminologies in interaction with the
environment and the environment for me
started in my mother's womb and then was
when I was raised as a in front and then
as a child in Spain and the schools to
which I went and studies I did and who
were my friends and and you know what
were my activities and then I came to
the United States and all those
experiences determine what we are so if
somebody we are going to take my genes
and create another human with those
genes it will be genetically identical
to me but he will not be me why in the
world would he want to clone a human
being one of the great attributes of
human kindness the diversity that we
have we want to have a herd of identical
individuals our diversity of
personalities appearances styles and
iris and everything else is the one of
the great gifts of humankind
I can choose in the next minute not to
talk to you or say something very kind
of very obnoxious some philosophers
argue that free will is does not exist
humans have free will and they are the
only animals that have free will in my
view because we are the only animals who
have kind of salted intelligence that we
have which allows us to explore
alternative courses of action to
anticipate the consequences of our
actions and other ways in which we
exercise our free will
there are many religious people who are
also scientist and that see the Legion
as science certainly has not in
opposition and more if anything with
having possible areas of complementation
but I think a majority don't think about
the issues there are many religious
people who are also scientist and many
scientists were religious another who
may not be many religious people are not
scientists but they don't think
antagonistically about the about science
they simply don't think about the issues
and the story also for many scientists
most scientists are not thinking about
what their compatibility the
compatibility of the science with a
religion